المعارك في بحموت لا تتوقف قريبا هذا ما
كشف عنه اجتماع قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
بالاجماع قررت هذه القياده لاستمرار في
الدفاع عن بخموت قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان
الهدف هو تدمير المهتل
التركيز الاساسي هو في اتجاه خرتيسيا
وباخمت هناك موقف عام لدى القياده
العسكريه وهو المضي في هذا الاتجاه لتدمير
المحتل بالطبع نعمل باستمرار على امداد
الجبهه بالذخيره
يرى كثير من الخبراء العسكريين انه لم
يبقى هناك معنى عسكري لاستمرار
الاوكرانيين في الدفاع عن ضخمه التي لا
تكتسي في نظرهم اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره
ولن يغير سقوطها مجرى الحرب
لكن القياده الاوكرانيه وان كانت تعترف
بان خطر محاصره المدينه من كل الجهات يلوح
في الافق فانها تسر على الدفاع عنها ميخيل
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني قال ان قوات
بلاده تحارب في ضخمه لان استمرار المعارك
يعوق تحرك افضل وحدات الجيش الروسي ويلحق
بها اضرارا كبيره قبيل الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد قريبا يعترف الطرفان بصعوبه القتال
في ضخمه التي تشهد حاليا معارك خنادق تذكر
بالحرب العالميه الاولى
هنا يتم التقدم بيتا بيتا ما يرفع من عدد
القتلى والجرحى في الطرفين رئيس اقليم
دونتسك المعين من قبل روسيا دونيس بوشيرين
قال ان هناك معارك طاحنه من اجل كل متر في
المدينه واضاف ان ما سماه النظام
الاوكراني لا يهتم بعدد القتلى في صفوفه
اما قائد ميليشيا فاغنر الذي تقود قواته
الهجوم الروسي على بخمه فقد قال انه واثق
من ان الاوكرانيين يعدون هجوما مضاده لفك
الحصار الذي اقترب من اكماله على المدينه
[موسيقى]
تقترب معركه بخموت من اكمال شهرها السابع
هي اطول معارك حرب اوكرانيا واكثرها دمويه
بالنسبه للطرفين لم تعد اهدافها تقتصر على
الجانب العسكري تحولت الى رمز للمقاومه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا وسقوطها يمكن ان يؤثر
على الروح المعنويه للجنود الاوكرانيين
وقد تتحول الى رمز للانتصار بالنسبه للروس
الذين لم يحققوا نصرا كبيرا منذ منتصف
السنه الماضيه في هذا لا تتوقف المعارك في
ضخمه